we call it the Green Monster or
something cooler than that like pretty
much whatever you wanna call it the
important part is issues arrows instead
of crossbow bolts 260 pound draw weight
the arrows exit the gate at 400 FPS
that's feet per second integrated recoil
energy dissipation adjustable mounts go
quick detach quiver pistol grip finger
gar it's non-slip rubber insert
hey everybody we got a whole bunch of
arrow to talk about there's also some
big flash news about an upcoming episode
they're doing some Rick and Morty stuff
that I'll explain at the end of the
video so there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video a couple of you
may have spotted the new comic book
character they introduced from Batman's
under the Red Hood storyline called onyx
this week but I think they did a good
job of telling you what the timeline is
for Diggle as Green Arrow what he is
doing to enable him to continue being
Green Arrow that big post-credits scene
in number 10 sort of teeing up the intro
narration Oliver explains in the new
version of the intro that the reason why
he passed the mantle is is because he's
trying to keep his promise to be
William's father as with all things on
TV people always jump to the wrong
conclusion first before they figure
things out and then make the right
decision so Oliver will probably
eventually come to the conclusion that
he can beat both Williams dad and do a
good job at that and be the green arrow
at the same time no matter what Slade
said back during episode 1 but number 9
they have that first big carpark safe
with Diggle jumping off the building
there's actually a pretty cool shot of
the Black Canary using her sonic scream
to blast him the rest of the way to the
landing on that other building so I do
like that they're using her abilities in
more creative ways this season like she
isn't just using it to explode people's
heads like watermelons but number 8
Oliver and William felt like a pretty
big deal in this episode so obviously
the next couple of episodes will be
Oliver doing this and Diggle being the
green arrow so you're gonna see more of
him just being a regular dad trying to
be mayor during the day like he had to
deal with a botched save when they blew
up that truck from the other side of
things normally it'd be him doing that
and then somebody else in the mayor's
office having to watch it on the news
the next morning but you may remember
that the last time they had breakfast
was actually during the season 4
premiere I think they were making eggs
they were trying to make something like
Felicity was trying to make omelets and
kept burning them I don't think that
we've actually had a breakfast scene at
all of any kind since then but maybe
that's just a coincidence the way they
used the eggs in this episode with them
bonding in the felicity Oliver storyline
that was going on in the background like
her slowly moving back into his life but
number 7 we meet that new Batman
character on
the comic book version of her character
is pretty much what you saw in the TV
show she's not a metahuman she doesn't
have any special powers but she was
trained by the League of Assassins so
she's just a total badass she was there
for the under the Red Hood storyline I
was actually expecting to see her
connect up with either the Richer dragon
or the black sirens storyline because it
seems like they're busting people out
and there's gonna be some sort of
team-up forming in the next couple of
episodes but the way they played her
storyline is that she had her own agenda
just going after a hundred million
dollars in gold that she and a bunch of
her former CIA black ops comrades stole
from the Syrian government so she was
just going after the people in her group
to get at that gold and using the nerve
gas to do that so there were a couple
people in my timeline they were asking
about the green serum they like is this
more like mirakuru
what's going on with court industries
are they trying to remake that no that's
just the nerve gas Kord industries makes
a lot of weapons tech they're sort of
like the Stark Industries of the
arrowverse number six there were a
couple big Easter eggs with felicity and
Oliver when he went to ask her for help
with William she talks about the 80s
sitcom she's talking about step by step
bit by bit there's a whole bunch of
other funny names written on the board
here I could only read a couple of them
there's Oracle there's Scientology as in
Scientology infinity industries in ER d
as in nerd but they're probably way more
Easter eggs and some of these funny
names so write them below in the
comments of you spot em all the whole
idea with the company and the name that
they're thinking of that will probably
wind up being smoke technologies if you
don't remember that
Oliver had a vision of it they saw it on
legends of tomorrow in the alternate
future timeline where we saw connor
hawke so i don't know how long it's
going to be before they come up with
that name but that's the name that
they're probably going to come up with
maybe it'll be before the mid-season
finale maybe it'll be in the mid-season
finale but number five problems inside
new team arrow Diggle botches the save
this is this big storyline with him
doubting his competence so wild dog
tries to get Oliver to come back I think
we all understood that he's not gonna
come right back they just want to make
you wonder how he's gonna handle all
this pressure and how he's gonna deal
with his injury but they sort of use
that as the subplot for this
anti-vigilante legislation in Oliver's
11th hour save for that at the end
before this
he votes it in is that he turns it over
to the people so if it wasn't clear what
was happening when he was invoking
Chapter nine of the city charter is is
it instead of the City Council voting on
that anti-vigilante bill now it's going
to be turned into this big citywide
thing so all the people of the city will
decide whether or not to outlaw
vigilantes so the big challenge there is
as the diggle can't screw up if he keeps
screwing up then it'll look bad for
vigilantes people will start hating them
and they'll want them gone so they have
all this pressure mounting in the
background which is probably why
diggle's juicing himself with whatever
cocktail he gets at the end of the
episode but I wouldn't be surprised if
that comes to a vote before the
mid-season finale and that's sort of a
ticking clock for them like we have to
do a really good job as new team arrow
otherwise they will outlaw all
vigilantes in the city if you saw a
legends of tomorrow they'd have like an
alternate future timeline where
metahumans get outlawed everywhere this
is just a way of reminding you of that
there's a lot of subtle crossover
between the show's like where you see
the newspaper with Oliver being out as
Green Arrow on the flash like hey wait a
minute what's going on here but number
four the whole deal with Oliver giving
Felicity the key to his apartment so
they might be building up towards like a
second marriage during the big
mid-season crossover they certainly went
a long way in the episode towards making
Felicity feel like she was really good
with William like Oliver says I feel
like he's better with you in his life
like I'm better with you in my life
so it seems like they want to paint a
picture of it being a good thing that
she become part of like their little
family unit so whether or not that means
marriage later this season who knows
there have been a lot of rumors about
that and even though it seemed kind of
saccharine like there very clearly
telegraphing that they're getting back
together and it even made it sound like
they've been together on the DL before
this and now they're just being more
open about it with everyone else but one
of the things that they haven't quite
got to yet is all the Michael Emerson
stuff that's going on with her character
so there hasn't been a whole lot of
drama with her in the background this
season she had all the drama with helix
last season and I believe that the helix
characters were in the season 6 trailer
so that will probably come back to haunt
her but they just haven't got to that
storyline yet so number 3 was
big fight at the end of the episode they
did a big action set piece I guess if
you're on Team arrow you're not allowed
to walk down the staircase
you always have to jump off the rooftop
or over a balcony you have to do with
the superhero landing way Diggle had a
really cool fight with onyx inside the
car it looked like something right out
of Luke Cage but it's sort of his call
to action moment where he doubts himself
but then he gets his [ __ ] together on
the green arrow so there was a lot of
awkward comedy in the episode where
people were like are we gonna have some
sort of new traditions now and diggle's
like no we're not gonna do things
differently it'll be the exact same so
if you couldn't tell there were a couple
things going on in the background of
this Diggle trying to be a good leader
storyline where black Canary's seemed
like she had his back a hundred percent
the whole time like they want to make
her seem like she could be a good leader
- she has absolutely zero self-doubt she
makes all these really snap decisions
real quick this is what you need to do
this is how you need to do it they
showed her being a really good detective
so it sounds like they're just trying to
present her is this really self-assured
smart character in in the comics and a
lot of the animated shows like Young
Justice Black Canary eventually becomes
one of the big team leaders she even
becomes the leader of one of the
iterations of the Justice League so I
think they're just laying groundwork for
her to be a really good team leader in a
future season as well so if you see her
giving sage wisdom to the other
characters the way that Oliver did in
this episode that's probably why but
speaking of which I totally loved all
the sage wisdom that Oliver laid on
Diggle they said that that's going to be
happening a lot more of the season for
his character less of other people
giving all of her advice in more of
Oliver giving other people advice so
it's just a function of him learning
from all the experiences that he's had
like he's not gonna keep making the same
stupid mistakes but number two is
diggle's new weapon the Green Monster
they even tease the idea that they're
gonna be future upgrades like he's gonna
keep using it even if he stops being
Green Arrow after the next couple of
episodes so it's pretty much exactly
what you saw is this a high powered
version of a crossbow that shoots arrows
like full-size arrows instead of regular
crossbow bolts but the big twist at the
end is that he's only able to do all
those things because he's juicing with
some cocktail to try and help balance
himself out so obviously that's gonna
slide downhill
they fast I don't think they're gonna
drag it out further than the mid-season
crossover like by that time Oliver will
have become the green arrow again but
the really big flash news I almost
forgot is that they're going to do a
council of ricks Rick and Morty style
episode but it'll be Harrison wells so
it'll be a Council of wells episode so
I'll do a video all about that in the
next couple of days there'll be plenty
of Flash stuff going on I have some new
Avengers to post and stranger things is
dropping this weekend too so I'll start
with a review video and then I'll be
posting some Easter eggs for that
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner nice and fly please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for that new
Justice League trailer and you can click
here for brand new flash thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight